ja meine Damen und Herren wer hätte das
gedacht selbst in der corona-krise wird
es gelegentlich noch lustig seit dieser
Woche zum Beispiel darf man Markus Söder
ganz offiziell als Gesetzesbrecher
bezeichnen ja der frei drehende Franke
wie die von ihm selber mit angeschobene
Impfpflicht für den Pflegebereich in
Bayern erstmal nicht umsetzen das Gesetz
dazu wurde erst im letzten Dezember in
Bundestag und Bundesrat beschlossen
inklusive der bekannten Mängel beim
Arbeitsrecht mit den Stimmen der Union
aber jetzt im Februar sinken halt so das
Umfragewerte und deswegen deswegen
arbeiten wir daran großzügige
Übergangsregelung sondern was de facto
auf ein zunächst mal ein Aussetzen des
Vollzugs hinausläuft
ja der Faktor ist Latein und heißt so
viel wie fick dich Ampel ist reine
eigene sonst nichts und dann wundert man
sich dass das Vertrauen der Bürger in
die corona-maßnahmen immer weiter in den
Keller geht und immer schneller es
wirklich ein ganz ganz tolles Signal
Gesetze gelten es sei denn sie passen
eigentlich ja ist gut zu wissen dann ist
das ab jetzt eben so bei denen da unten
gute Nachrichten Bayern ab jetzt ist bei
euch alles egal nie wieder komplizierte
Steuererklärung schreibt in die doofen
Formulare einfach was ihr den Finanzamt
immer schon sagen wolltet nehmt Drogen
verkauft Drogen Gesetze waren gestern
parkt eure Autos wo immer ihr wollt
juckt keinen macht als CSU-Politiker so
viele krumme masken-deals wie möglich
und ich drehe durch es nach 12 Uhr noch
Weißwurst totale Anarchie denn der
ehemalige Freistaat Bayern heißt ab
sofort rechtsfreier Raum Bayern
ja Bayern das Eldorado der Gesetzlosen
ja ich weiß ja nicht wie Sie das sehen
liebe Zuschauer bei mir geht das alles
doch ein bisschen zu schnell Söder war
doch neulich noch selbst ernannter
Captain vom Team Vorsicht dann vom Team
Augenmaß dann vom Team Lockerung mit
fließendem Übergang zum Team mir doch
scheißegal und seinem absoluten
Lieblingsteam Team ich ja manche CDU
regierte Bundesländer folgen jetzt Söder
andere nicht Ergebnis maximale
Verwirrung herzlichen Glückwunsch die
Idee war doch mit dem Gesetz also dem
Gesetz zur Impfpflicht in Pflegeberufen
besonders Wohlen Rabe Menschen zum
Beispiel in Pflege und Altenheim endlich
besser zu schützen dieses Fakten
basierte Ziel stelle ich doch nicht in
Frage aus Angst vor der möglichen
Reaktion des ungeimpften Pflegepersonals
oder weil der Söder an einem neuen
soften Image arbeitet weil die
omicron-wand zwar steil aber doch
vielleicht eine Wand mit Türen und
Fenster sind eine hoffnungsvollere
Zukunft in dieser corona-wand den Weg
und die richtigen Türen finden durch die
man gehen kann sanfte und kontrollierte
Öffnung bevor wir zu den sanften
Öffnungen in Bayern kommen jetzt zum
sanften bayerischen Weg eine sanfte Wand
mit Türen und Fenstern durch die man
gehen kann ja eine sanfte Wand kommt auf
uns zu sanfte wann gibt zum Beispiel
eine Gummizelle allerdings ist da die
Tür meist abgeschlossen wobei ich sagen
muss die lockerungsdebatte an sich ist
selbstverständlich total legitim ganz
Europa lockert sich gerade ein und auch
die Deutsche Krankenhausgesellschaft
rechnet in absehbarer Zeit nicht mehr
mit einer Überlastung unseres
Gesundheitssystems die zu verhindern war
doch immer das Ziel aller
corona-maßnahmen jetzt kommt von
Lauterbach und Co meist ja aber wir
haben immer noch zu viele ungeimpfte
über 60
sagt man eigentlich ungeimpfte ich frage
mal Klaus Strunz ich übrigens sag lieber
nicht geimpfte als ungeimpfte weil für
meinem finden steckt in dem in der
Vorsilbe und eine Wertung drin Unheil
Unrat Unwahrheit alles was mit unanfängt
ist irgendwie negativ ja völlig richtig
jedes Wort mit un ist negativ Strunz zum
Beispiel oder Strunz doof oder
UN-Sicherheitsrat alles negativ was mich
im Moment am meisten aufregt ist das vor
allem Kinder und Jugendliche weiter
unter den corona-maßnahmen leiden ja
keiner muss mehr zurückstecken als die
keiner kriegt so oft Stäbchen in die
kleine Nase gerammt von ständiger
Quarantäne und lernrückständen mal ganz
zu schweigen hier Berlin schießt wie
immer den Vogel ab
das Land Berlin hebt auf Wunsch von
Eltern die Präsenzpflicht auf besonders
pikant daran ein Anspruch auf
distanzunterricht besteht nicht
nee natürlich nicht wie denn auch dafür
bräuchte eine Schule ja Internet in
Berlin und all das sollen die Kinder
klaglos auf sich nehmen um die alten zu
schützen mein ernsthaft wir können nicht
wirklich für drei Millionen immer noch
ungeimpfte über 60 die unter
Beratungsresistenz oder todes-sehnsucht
leiden weiter das Leben unserer Kinder
auf Pause Stellen über zwei Jahre geht
das schon so das schreit nach Rache sage
ich ihnen Vorschlag jeder einzelne
ungeimpfte Querdenker Opa kriegt zur
Strafe einmal am Tag Besuch von
Grundschülern und muss ich ohne zu
widersprechen erklären lassen wie doof
er ist
meine Fresse beim Menschen befindet sich
das Genom also die DNA mitten im
Zellkern das heißt der Impfstoff kann
dein Erbgut gar nicht verändern außerdem
an deine Stelle wäre ich froh wenn sie
das sehr gut verändert
und danach gibt es natürlich noch
mindestens eine Stunde
blockflötenkonzert
[Musik]
ich lass mich impfen aufhören
hoch verdient leider macht es die
aktuelle corona-politik ihren Gegnern
aber auch viel zu leicht Beispiel das
ganze PCR-Test Debakel dass wir gerade
erleben man steht ewig Schlange und
wartet teilweise tagelang auf sein
Ergebnis warum woanders geht das
deutlich besser bei unseren Nachbarn in
Wien zum Beispiel wo man sehr sehr
erfolgreich mit PCR Selbsttest zum
Gurgeln und spucken arbeitet meine ja
klar ist halt ein ganz anderes Konzept
bei denen unsere Idee möglichst viele
Tests zu der besten Qualität zu einem
extrem günstigen Preis zu machen in
Deutschland hat man anderes
Geschäftsmodell das sagt man will halt
möglichst wenig Tests machen zu
ermöglicht Strompreis heißt übersetzt
küss die Hand ihr Piefke Deppen wie blöd
kann man bitte sein
[Musik]
oh Gott der Dreh für die